[Musique]
à la une de ce 29 mars la faim de plus
de deux ans de travaux la rénovation du
lycée international de saint germain en
laye est achevé depuis quelques mois une
réhabilitation une extension de 25 mille
mètres carrés inauguré officiellement ce
matin l'établissement accueille de 1300
élèves de la maternelle à la classe
terminale des bâtiments chauffés grâce à
l'énergie produite par une route à
proximité du péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ce dispositif
est expérimenté depuis 2010 est la
chaleur du soleil et capté soulac ce
avant d'être redistribués et puis j - 12
avant le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle le dimanche 10 avril
prochain les électeurs devront faire
leur choix entre douze candidats si vous
ne pouvez pas vous déplacer aux urnes le
jour j il existe la solution procuration
comment ça marche on vous explique tout
dans cette édition
[Musique]
les chiffres du comité 19 en hausse en
france le rebond est aussi observée dans
les yvelines depuis l'allègement des
mesures sanitaires en moyenne la semaine
dernière 2600k quotidiens ont été
enregistrés dans le département soit une
multiplication par 2 en une semaine
situation qui se dégrade également de
nouveau à l'hôpital où les admissions
ont augmenté de 20% la semaine dernière
[Musique]
drapeau élèves personnalités politiques
le lycée international de saint germain
en laye a vécu ce mardi 29 mars une
inauguration en grande pompe un
événement organisé après trois ans de
travaux dans cet établissement installé
dans la commune depuis 1952 et qui avait
besoin d'un lifting la cour de
récréation était
tout sauf une cour est en tout cas pas
récréative la cantine était dans un état
déplorable
les salles de cours était d'une
tristesse infinie bref c'était un outil
qui ne vivaient que par la qualité de
l'enseignement donné et certainement pas
par le cadre qu on offre aux élèves pour
permettre aux 2300 élèves répartis dans
quatorze sections internationales
d'étudier dans les meilleures conditions
67 millions d'euros dont 28,7 millions
du département des mines ont été
débloqués le résultat semble satisfaire
la proviseure c'est très moderne c'est
très beau c'est du bois c'est duvet et
il ya un équipement numérique qui est
qui est vraiment tout à fait performant
avec 100 % de réussite au bac et 98 % de
mentions le lis internationaux de
saint-jean mansle et fait partie des
meilleurs établissements france cette
rénovation devrait permettre à la
structure de continuer dans cette voie
il est évident que le sujet du bâti
scolaire ce n'est pas seulement un sujet
immobilier c'est un sujet pédagogique
c'est un sujet de projets pédagogiques
c'est particulièrement important pour
les apprentissages lorsqu'on est bien
dans son corps dans l'espace eh bien on
apprend bien et on apprend mieux au
total 25 mille mètres carrés de
planchers ont été ajoutés sur le site
avec cette rénovation les élèves
espèrent maintenant être à la hauteur de
ces structures qui fête cette année ses
70 ans
[Musique]
cette signature hier lundi à elancourt
la commune à renouveler officiellement
son label de ville amie des enfants elle
le sera au moins jusqu'en 2026 le label
est attribué par l'unicef pour
distinguer les collectivités qui
s'engagent à appliquer la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant et
mettre en place des actions en faveur
des 0 à 10 80 13 communes d i mean sont
amies des enfants elancourt qu'il est
devenu pour la première fois en 2004 est
récompensé pour ses trente et une
initiative à destination des jeunes dont
quatorze nouvelles actions la ville a
profité de la signature pour annoncer
également le déblocage d'une aide de
5000 euros pour l'unicef dédié aux
enfants ukrainiens on a choisi
effectivement de mettre en place
quatorze nouvelles actions qui tout
effectivement rentrer dans les
dents ce que l'unicef demandait aux
communes à savoir que que l'on fasse
aussi de de la pédagogie de la
parentalité que l'on défende aussi les
valeurs du sport et que l'on défend des
fouilles près des familles le bien-être
des enfants que ce soit par le biais de
la nutrition par le biais aussi des
actions parentalité et des conférences
qu'on va pouvoir mener aux familles
parce que c'est une c'est une vraiment
façon d'abord pour nous de faire avancer
les droits de l'enfant et de les faire
avancer dans les selon les mêmes
principes et c'est aussi il ya une
solidarité entre les villes et entre
l'unicef et les villes est avec nous
[Musique]
les élections présidentielle et
législatives arrivent à grands pas si
vous êtes dans l'incapacité de vous
rendre dans votre bureau de vote mais
que vous souhaitez aller voter pouvez
faire une procuration
elle permet de mandater quelqu'un pour
aller voter à votre place alors
concrètement comment ça marche et bien
une procuration s'effectue en deux
étapes étape une il vous faut remplir
vos informations et celle de votre
mandataire deux choix s'offrent alors à
vous vous pouvez soit faire une demande
en ligne via la plateforme ma
procuration point gouv.fr soit remplir
un formulaire papier il est disponible
sur le site de l'administration
française services tirés public.fr la
procédure peut être la procédure de
démarches en ligne peut-être simplifie
énormément les choses il faut a disposé
effectivement une certaine information
mais qui vous sont demandées sur la
démarche en lits et ça simplifie à ce
moment là quand on passe sur le site ça
simplifie énormément
la procédure de validation ce que
j'assiste des sceaux et de choses n'a
d'abord la démarche est ensuite la
validation par nos fils y est policière
[Musique]
ce qui nous amène à notre deuxième étape
pour faire valider votre identité et
donc votre demande il faut vous rendre
dans l'un de ces deux lieux donc une
brigade de gendarmerie ou un
commissariat
vous devez être munis d'un justificatif
d'identité et selon votre choix
précédents soin de votre formulaire
papier elle soit du numéro de référence
que vous avez obtenus lors de votre
demande en ligne
qu'est ce qui change cette année par
rapport aux années précédentes
eh bien depuis le 1er janvier 2022 vous
pouvez choisir de donner votre voix un
électeur extérieur à votre commune par
contre la personne en question devra
bien entendu se déplacer à dans le
bureau de vote où vous êtes inscrits
pour faire exprimer votre voix une
procuration peut s'effectuer à n'importe
quel moment attention cependant aux
délais de traitement de votre demande et
à l'acheminement jusqu'à votre commune
évitez de vous y prendre à la dernière
minute on écoute pourquoi se mobilise
beaucoup de gens
de façon
intense dans les deux semaines qui
précèdent l'élection vous avez
possibilité de faire une procuration
pour une élection en particulier elle
serait alors à préciser lors de votre
démarche vous pouvez également faire une
procuration pour une durée déterminée
jusqu'à un an au maximum si vous êtes
inscrit sur une liste électorale
communale à noter si vous êtes
finalement dans la capacité d'aller
voter le jour j pas besoin de résilier
votre procuration et s'est fait
simplement d'informer votre mandataire
vous pourrez alors allés voter
personnellement dans votre bureau de
vote il celui ci n'est pas venu bien
évidemment voté à votre place avant vous
prochaine échéance pour les élections
les 10 et 24 avril pour les
présidentielles et les 12 et 19 juin
pour les législatives
[Musique]
bonjour je suis martial femmes
appartenant à l'ufr l'union française
des retraités retraité depuis 2015 il
intervient à ce titre monsieur mac on
nous a appliqué sur la csg 25% l'a fait
augmenter au 1er janvier 2018 donc ça
c'était déjà pas une bonne une bonne
nouvelle ensuite il a lancé une europe
une réforme sur les retraites qui n'a
pas abouti peut-être espérons qu'elle
aboutira un jour si c'est encore lui
aussi c'est un autre
[Musique]
l'ufr a envoyé naître présidentiables à
tous les candidats mise en place d'un
régime universel c'est ce qu'on
demandait s'ils commençaient à se faire
puisque savez qu'il ya quarante deux
régimes de retraite donc on souhaiterait
qu'il n'est plus qu'un entre guillemets
sachant que la sncf l'edf et tout ça ça
va être un petit peu plus difficile
parce qu'ils ont des systèmes de
retraite très particulier ensuite on
souhaitait aussi garantir un minima
l'indexation des pensions sur les prix
les solutions c'est je crois qu'il doit
y avoir un petit système de retraites
chacun de faire une partie de sa
retraite vous regardez le régime de
répartition ça c'est tout à fait
d'accord mais on voit que chacun alors
c'est sûr que pour les petits salaires
ça va être très difficile pour les
moyens salaires ça peut encore se faire
pour les gros salaires je ne parle pas
ça c'est évident mais voilà l'une des
solutions qui peut être préconisées tout
ce qu'on souhaite aussi c'est qu'il ya
un dialogue qui n'est pas qu'ils soient
pas à sens unique comme ça a été le cas
on l'a vu avec les îles et journée avec
qu'ovide avec tous ces expériences là
[Musique]
et sinon se chauffer grâce à nos routes
c'est déjà possible avec power road
développé par revient le concept est
simple capter la chaleur du soleil sur
les routes grâce à des tubes inséré sous
la chaussée la chaleur sera alors
stockée pure et distribué via des pompes
à chaleur pour des besoins de proximité
l'été les routes vont chauffer leurs
vêtements va monter en température
environ 60 degrés donc en fait on a eu
l'idée de mettre dans la deuxième couche
de la route des tubes des tubes dans
lequel on va faire circuler un fluide
caloporteur va le faire passer dans les
sondes géothermiques on va augmenter la
température naturel de la terre qui aux
alentours de 15 degrés ça c'est l'été et
quand on a besoin l'hiver donc de
chauffer un bâtiment des logements une
piscine un gymnase à ce moment là on va
utiliser on va extraire les calories qui
sont dans ce volume de termes concernés
par les cendres géothermique on va
extraire avec des pompes à chaleur d'une
manière classique pour chauffer tous ces
équipements aurore bergé député des
yvelines s'est rendu à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ou le premier
démonstrateur il ya été mise en service
en 2018 500 m² de chaussée power ont été
mises en place elles permettent
actuellement de chauffer un bâtiment de
370 m² et de déneiger les 500 m² de la
voirie concernés en hiver ici c'est les
tubes qui vont aller jusqu'à l'arbre
dont ceux qui reviennent directement ici
qui prennent un bon coup c'est tout le
fluide et doivent pas jusque là bas dans
les tubes qui sont ici les sondes
géothermiques vont durer plus de 50 ans
donc on aura une pompe à chaleur a
changé tous les 25 ans on va dire
globalement notre installation peut
tenir entre 30 et 50 ans sans aucun
souci une énergie thermique
renouvelables et invisible qui
contribuent à la transition énergétique
et à la lutte contre la précarité
énergétique je termine c'est une chaleur
renouvelable locale qui est pour
l'instant très peu utilisé évidemment il
ya l'installation à payer mais après on
est tout simplement dans quelque chose
qui est gratuit c'est en substitution à
des énergies fossiles comme le gaz ça
permet effectivement de pouvoir réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre on
a souvent des débats vous le savez sur
le photovoltaïque sur l'éolien à la fois
parce que c'est un coût mais aussi sur
la question des paysages place est
invisible cesson au pied donc on a en
plus je crois vraiment un potentiel de
développement qui est énorme la solution
pour un road permet d'économiser jusqu'à
80 % de co2 par rapport à une chaudière
à gaz
[Musique]
c'est l'un des plus grands golf d'île de
france avec ses 36 trous le golf blue
green de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
aspire à être un des ponts vers d'un
secteur très urbanisé peut effectivement
voir après une semaine de
d'aération on voit les petites roues ya
quatre centres ou aux médias comme 13
autres de la franchise bluegreen le golf
a obtenu le symbolique label bronze pour
ses actions écologiques derrière moi on
peut effectivement voir des zones de ce
qu'on appelle deux aux rough qui sont
des zones donc du coup non tondue qui en
font partie effectivement c'est un
dossier qu'on remplit et on met en avant
toutes les actions qu'on fait pour être
dans ce label fauchage tardif
réduction des phytosanitaires emploi de
méthodes alternatives
réduction des hauteur de tonte pour
réduire la consommation d'eau tout ce
qui va être finalement enclin à
améliorer non pas notre bilan carbone
mais notre impact sur la nature en tout
cas là la minimiser au maximum essayé de
faire des choses bien des étapes
supérieures sont accessibles dans le
futur les labels argent puis or qui
récompense un travail encore plus
concret pour l'environnement le label
rond c'est le tout premier label qui dit
en gros que on est conscient des
bienfaits de l'écologie et par des
actions assez simple que d'ailleurs
beaucoup de golf met en place en tout
cas chez blue green
on arrive à accéder à ce premier ce
premier stade c'est extrêmement
important déjà parce que l'image du lol
souvent est assez assez négative ce qui
comme nous disait tout à l'heure notre
hymne purger un pic au ski une mauvaise
image et qui n'est pas juste parce que
le golf c'est effectivement un poumon
vert dès le 1er avril le golf sera
enclin à faire découvrir gratuitement
ces parcours aux visiteurs pour une
longue période de portes ouvertes
jusqu'à la mi mai
[Musique]
et puis c'est dans un peu plus de deux
ans les jeux olympiques de 2024 se
dérouleront à paris le cojo comité
d'organisation vient de lancer une
campagne de recrutement pour les
étudiants en alternance 80 postes sont à
pourvoir entre le 28 mars et le 6 juin
un ingénieur architecte ou encore
responsable de projet et d'événements et
des missions qui se dérouleront au siège
du cojep saint denis pour plus
d'informations et postulez rendez vous
sur la plateforme de recrutement en
ligne de paris 2024 et belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]